let's try instead three four seven who's
calling today from the three four seven
area code hello yes that's you
hey David um big fan of your show thank
you um I have a I have a question do you
which Democratic ticket do you think
would be best which candidates president
and vice president do you think would
win that's because I know there are a
lot of mixes and matches that would be
Trump but I know there are a lot that
aren't there are a lot that wouldn't
what is your opinion I have not thought
about vice presidential at all so I
really couldn't tell you I mean what as
far as what the polling says right now
in terms of who could beat Trump in the
general you know both Bernie and Biden
do really well against Trump and
hypothetical polls Harrison Warren do
well but not quite as well I'm just sort
of going from memory here but as far as
VP I mean listen in one sense I don't
think VP is going to matter that much in
2020 I think that this thing is going to
be won or lost on a couple of things one
turnout in a few key states who gets
slightly more people to vote number two
how much voter suppression takes place
and number three how well the eventual
Democratic nominee is going to be able
to fight back against Trump's personal
attacks and his style during the debates
the VP candidate is ultimately only
going to debate Mike Pence or whoever
replaces Mike Pence on the ticket if
he's replaced that's not gonna matter
nearly as much as the the other things
that I mentioned so I honestly I have
not thought about VP at all mmm
that's interesting I believe that since
there are a lot of popular Democratic
candidates that that are could be
popular in one area but really really
unpopular in another area I know I know
that we have a lot of I know I very much
like Andrew yang well actually no he
might not be the best example but there
are a lot of coastal elites Democratic
candidates that I don't think could do
well in the south and there are a lot of
it's a Biden or you know actually say
Warren or say maybe even well I guess if
we're not going to count the straight
white candidates that there won't really
make the second round of debates but I
don't think people like Warren could
really make the make people in the
Midwest or even on the west coast very
no I I generally think that you're right
you are correct that different
candidates will appeal to different
pieces of the electorate to different
degrees I actually think you're wrong
about Warren Warren does really well
when she goes to the Midwest and talks
to trump voters and explains policy I
actually think that she will do better
than people give her credit for although
I completely agree with what you're
saying that the idea of north eastern
liberals in the deep south for example
it there may be some lack of appeal
there but I actually think Warren does
really well when she talks to red state
voters I might look into that that's
very interesting thank you for talking
with me I appreciate it yeah thank you
for the call great to hear from you